hey everyone i'm john coogan and welcome
to the fourth installment of my guide to
startup fundraising
last week i talked about how to meet
investors and today i'm going to talk
about building a great deck
remember building a great deck doesn't
mean you've built a great business
you need to make sure your company is
making its customers happy growing the
customer base significantly every month
and has a giant pool of potential
customers if you've done all that
you might not even need a deck to close
a big round decks come into play when a
professional investor
is ready to make a decision on whether
or not to invest most
angel investors never need to see a deck
to make a decision they just want to
talk to you directly and hear about the
business
but for professional investors like seed
funds and vc firms
you'll need to pitch a larger audience
and have some materials that can be
circulated within the firm
it can be intimidating to think about
all the different people that will judge
you based on this deck
but don't let that stop you from keeping
it simple stay concise
eight to ten slides are perfect for a
seed round you might expand this to
15 or 20 slides for a series a but the
information always needs to be laid out
in a clean and simple manner
remember after investors sign a term
sheet they can request
more specific information during due
diligence which we'll talk about in a
later video
never waste money buying complicated
templates or paying for design services
i've linked two great slide deck
templates from y combinator and sequoia
capital below
they might seem overly simplistic but
just look at any apple keynote and
you'll see how effective slides can be
when they keep things straightforward
during a pitch the deck shouldn't be the
main attraction vcs invest in people
not decks so you want to be able to have
a great conversation and just use the
slides to guide things
focus on short bullet points and key
takeaways instead of full sentences or
paragraphs
a great slide deck will cover the
following 10 items your company's
purpose
the problem the solution the why now the
market size
the competition your product your
business model the founding team
and your financials and traction let's
go through them one by one
we talked about the elevator pitch
before and your company's purpose slide
is a great opportunity to reiterate that
this description isn't just for the
investor you're currently meeting with
it's also the phrase that they'll repeat
internally at their firm
and potentially send to other investors
who they collaborate with
make it clear make it concise and make
it memorable
substack did a great job of this with
their first major deck when substack
launched in 2018
patreon had already raised over 100
million dollars and most investors were
familiar with that model
but it hadn't been widely adopted by
newsletter writers additionally ben
thompson had proved that independent
writers could gain lots of subscribed
followers with his newsletter
clearly describing who the customer is
and what you do for them
is critical to keeping this slide
memorable describing the problem in the
solution is the best way to introduce
investors to your market opportunity
in talking about the problem make sure
to describe who the customer is
what their pain is or what they don't
have the ability to do today
and then talk about how they solve this
problem currently
the solution slide is where you
demonstrate your company's value
proposition
and how you solve the customer's problem
this is a great place to show how your
customer uses your product and what
value they get out of it
this format works for all kinds of
startups but airbnb has a particularly
good set of slides on the problem and
the solution
they highlight three common problems
when traveling the high price of current
options
the lack of community when staying in a
hotel and the fact that people with
extra space can't easily host travelers
to make extra money
their solution is a web platform that
lets users rent out their space to host
travelers
in doing so airbnb users can save money
while traveling
make money while hosting and connect to
the city
after you've articulated the problem in
the solution you'll need to explain why
this is the best time to start a company
focused on providing a solution
timing is super important in startups if
a particular technology is not quite
polished enough
or affordable yet you could be too soon
to gain wide adoption
conversely if you enter the market too
late
there will likely be plenty of
competitors providing a better solution
already
the social media management company
buffer did a great job of explaining the
growth of social media
in 2010 when they launched they showed
that social media was basically
doubling every year and they make the
case that soon
every business would need to manage
social media pages buffers products are
designed to make this easier
so even though the need might have been
small back in 2010
it was the right time to focus on
building tools for social media
management
it's not enough to just be building
something in a growing market investors
have to believe that the size of your
market will eventually be huge
this slide serves to profile who you
will ultimately generate revenue from
and how big the opportunity is you can
think about this in three ways
the total available market or tam which
is a very broad
top-down approach that captures all of
the revenue in a given market
then there's the serviceable available
market which is the part of the tam
targeted to your products and services
specifically
lastly there's the serviceable
obtainable market or som
which is the part of the market that you
can actually capture you want to strike
a balance here and come up with a number
that isn't so huge that you'll get
laughed at
but isn't so small that you've left out
obvious adjacent markets that you could
expand into
linkedin did a great job of sizing their
market in 2004 when they raised their
series b
they highlighted three key areas where
they could monetize the service
and offered comparable products and
market sizes for each
remarkably their total market size was
just over 10 billion dollars in this
deck
and in 2020 linkedin is estimated to
earn over 8 billion
in revenue not bad for a 16 year old
prediction
the competition slide can be a tough one
because entrepreneurs often don't like
admitting that there are other people
working on the same thing it makes their
ideas seem less
novel but it's a fact of life if you're
going after a big problem there will be
other companies offering solutions
already
you want to make sure that you're not
just listing competitors though you want
to show how you're different
it's common practice to use a 2x2 matrix
to illustrate your market position
front app did a great job of this in
their series a deck the company makes a
shared inbox so multiple people can
collaborate on emails together
typically options for this fell into two
separate categories
business ready and good messaging
experience and there wasn't much
overlap front was aiming to create
business software that would feel as
intuitive to use as consumer apps like
gmail and facebook messenger
this slide clearly shows how they stand
out from the competition
now that the customer and market are
clear in the investor's mind
you need to focus on your product and
solutions specifically
you need to break down your form factor
functionality features and intellectual
properties so everyone in the meeting
understands what you're building
investors try out lots of startups but
certain products
especially in enterprise and biotech
might not be immediately relevant to an
investor
so go into enough detail here to make it
easy to visualize your product
front app did a great job of explaining
their product in their fundraising deck
because it's a bit of a complicated
enterprise product with lots of features
they use two slides to illustrate the
design first
they show you a basic screenshot that
gives you a look at the app as the
customer would see it
then they flip to a second slide with
call outs for all the different features
tucking those advanced features into a
friendly design is their main value
proposition
so it's important to call out these in
the deck your business model is how you
plan to make money from all those
customers who love using your product
you should explain your pricing
structure how much you typically earn
from a customer
and how you plan on acquiring new
customers twine.fm
is a platform for freelancers who create
content for brands
their business model slide is extremely
straightforward they take a 20
commission on all transactions that
happen on their platform
sometimes you may need to explain your
plans in more detail like foursquare did
in their 2011 pitch deck
since foursquare was a social network it
was free to use for the end user
and they relied on monetization from
local businesses foursquare's initial
business model didn't work well though
and they had to pivot so be sure you're
really testing your assumptions here
the team at the earliest stages this is
the most important slide of the deck
investors will often make bets on
talented founders even though they
aren't sure that the current business
will work out
you need to show that you have the
experience and determination to make
your startup successful no matter what
investors want to know that there is a
committed team on board with the
relevant skills to build and manage the
company as it grows
square's first pitch deck is a great
example of how to highlight your team
the founders were very well known in
silicon valley for their previous work
and it was clear that they could manage
a high-growth tech company today
square is worth over 60 billion dollars
companies that aren't growing
can't really call themselves startups
they're just small businesses
showing big growth numbers is going to
be the data that proves the hypothesis
you've laid out in the rest of the deck
you've explained how the business works
but in order to merit investment you
have to be growing
and the faster the better the analytics
company mixpanel
outlined their growth very clearly in
this fundraising deck
the exact figures have been redacted but
you can see that the growth curve is
up and to the right they also include a
sample summary of their financing to
date
which helps investors understand where
the company is and what the next round
might look like
linkedin also demonstrated a great
technique for showing growth
they started by showing what their
initial growth projections were when
they raised their series a
and then on the next slide they show
what actually happened they outperformed
significantly
and it's really clear from the slide
that they're onto something real
decks are just one small piece of the
fundraising puzzle and in many cases you
might not need a deck at all
so don't spend too much time building it
remember that they're just a tool to
structure your thoughts
and are never really a replacement for
an engaging conversation
ideally the deck will drift into the
background as you start diving into
different opportunities for where the
company could go
and how big the opportunity is next week
i'll talk about how to read a term sheet
and close a deal
so hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell if you want to be notified when
that goes live
if you have any questions about decks or
think i missed something please leave me
a comment below
thanks for watching